need motivation watching top 10 with
believe nation what's that belief nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being interested in politics from a
very young age to having the first
nationally syndicated column at age 17
to now running a highly successful
political radio show the venture PR show
he's Ben Shapiro and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make good decisions what I always
say to folks is show me the evidence of
where you're being victimized by a
particular person so I can fight that
alongside you or get your nose to the
grindstone right you can't you can't
just claim generalized victimhood you
can't just claim generalized white
privilege you can't just claim that
there's something out there in the ether
preventing you from succeeding you have
to show me which policy is preventing
you from succeeding or the person who is
standing in your way who's preventing
your success and then I'm on your side
because I don't want to see that person
stop you from doing anything you want to
do either but if you don't have any of
that and it's just you saying that your
life situation sucks well buck up I mean
get over it like most people throughout
history have had life situations that
suck I'm lucky I've had a really nice
life I've had a really nice pretty easy
life but that's not true of my
grandparents and finally not for your
grandparents it's not true of most
people's grand yarders our great
grandparents and so the bottom line is
and even for people who you know have
lived a relatively easy life it's not
like they've gone through a period they
haven't gone through periods that were
really rough I mean there's no question
that there's been stuff in my life I
don't like to talk about my personal
life very much but there's been stuff in
my life that certainly been very
difficult and that doesn't mean that you
know I can blame that on society nor
should anybody else I mean bottom line
is as I say if I had a slogan you know
aside from the facts don't care about
your feelings you'd be solve your own
problems because most problems are I
can't solve your problems for you and
either can society you can solve most of
the problems that are in front of you
and you certainly can't complain about
society victimizing you when you're not
making the most basic decisions in order
to prevent yourself from being
victimized right if you're somebody who
got pregnant at 17 and had a baby out of
wedlock that was a bad decision right
you made a bad decision there and that's
a consequence you're gonna have to bear
now the question is gonna make a series
of good decisions to help get yourself
out of that hole and make sure the
introducing all the time right good not
all the time or are you gonna sit there
and complain that America's an unfair
place because as a single mother you
have to face so many more obstacles of
course you have to face so many more
obstacles there was a decision that was
made that has some obvious ramifications
in the real world and that's not to say
they are a bad person it is to say that
a bad decision is a bad decision
regardless of who's making it as I'm
going to race it has nothing to the
class right anybody who makes bad
decision is going to pay for that bad
decision in one way or another so make
good decisions and then you're gonna
have less to complain about as a general
matter rule number two keep evolving
people saying that it's it's not your
fault because you're being screwed by
some foreign country it's not your fault
because the immigrants are doing it to
you yeah
it's not your fault maybe some maybe
some of that's true but you have to show
me why it's true we have to show me what
the actual like did you lose your job
because of and because of China or did
you lose your job because you're in an
industry that is being crowded out
because of technological change and
because your unions struck and created
wages too high to be globally
competitive like let's look at the
actual logic here as to and how then how
can we change it how can we make it
better how can we is it something we
have to do or is it a matter of you need
to broaden your skill set like you see a
lot of people now who are stuck in the
mindset of 30 years ago that you're
gonna work a job and stay there for 20
years and then you're gonna grow and
then you're gonna you know leave with a
gold watch and that's not the way the
job market works anymore I mean if
you're untying the job market right now
as a college student you can expect that
in the next 10 years you'll probably
work for jobs you know like the the
turnover is too great and you have to be
constantly increasing your skill set
rule number three be resourceful so when
I say to college students are really
politically motivated is go to leftist
campuses go to leftist campuses learn
how to hold in your arguments become a
weapon and what that and what I also
tell them is if you're gonna be on a
leftist campus don't be stupid if the
professor is going to grade you down for
being conservative in class right like a
communist I mean this is actually what I
did when I was at UCLA I'd argue with
the professor in class and then we had
things called blue books and blue books
well great because they were anonymous
they just used your student ID number
and so if you read my actual essays from
college they read like something
directly out of the nation and if you
you know and the obvious that's not what
I think but that's how you get to
graduate summa [ __ ] laude at UCLA go to
Harvard Law School and then use all
their degrees against them rule number
four think as an individual I think he
is that everybody is an independent
human being and you have to think as an
individual so that's why I say you know
no matter which house I grew up in I'm
sure they would have some impact on me
but I hope that as time went on I would
learn from life experiences and then I'd
start thinking as an individual not just
as my parents kid and not just as my my
wise husband but but and not just as you
know a Jewish guy but as somebody who
actually believes as an individual in
particular points of view and I said I
think you're starting to see that I
think the identity politics of the left
is starting to crumble a little bit
because it's become so restrictive you
know this belief that if you are a
member of a particular racial group that
you no longer are allowed to think
outside the box or if you're a member of
a particular sexual orientation you
can't think stuff that other people
don't want you to think a lot of folks
are starting to find this really
restrictive and galling and it's
melting and they're starting the thing
okay well maybe I'll take a look at some
other stuff for myself and when they're
folks not just like me but obviously
people like Jordan Peterson or Sam
Harris or Dave Rubin and people who are
all over the map politically but who are
saying listen it's time for you to take
a look at the data on your own and
figure out for yourself what you think
that's an empowering thing I'm not
telling anybody what they ought to think
I mean I'm telling them what I think but
you you're a grown-up right you can make
up your own mind but that's the point
you are growing up and it's your job to
make up your own mind it's not your job
to follow what your parents told you or
what your racial group says you ought to
do rule number five be driven I hope I'd
never retire because I just know too
many people who are retired and they're
oh I'm gonna retire and I'm gonna golf
another paint degree and six months
later they're dead do you have
aspirations outside of commentary when
it comes to politics
maybe some point down the road do you
think you run for president or something
like that I mean apparently anyone can
and this is what I'm finding yes sure so
um but you're a reasonable guy I don't
know I mean I I like what I'm doing in
the sense that I get to work on what
people believe which i think is sort of
the root of politics I'm not sure
implementing is the same thing as I said
I'm not sure that the president can get
like I'm more focused on getting people
to think in the terms that I'd like them
to think you know about limited
government and you taking control of
your own life and I might be able to do
more good you know promulgating that
message using a growing medium like
we're very lucky I mean or the podcast
went from having 3,000 listeners you
know 300 episodes ago to now we have
300,000 listeners a day you know so it's
it's it continues to grow so as that
crowd continues to grow it's actually
harder for me to say I'd want to jump
into politics not easier I think rule
number six rely on yourself somebody
says you know what I I just my mom told
me four years always will Democrat
because they care for the people
Republicans only care for the money
right so if someone says that what's
your safe to that answer to that is they
obviously don't care for the people
because the impact their policies has
been dramatically terrible they're
they're raking it in are you raking in
it really how's your life is your life
dramatically improved because of the
Democrats in your area you keep electing
if the answer is no then maybe they
don't care that much so you notice that
what I'm not doing is saying no no we do
care because once you engage in that
conversation somebody says I don't care
about you you don't care about me you
say no no I really do the conversation
is already over right if you're in a
relationship and your girlfriend says to
you you don't care about me anymore you
know I really do care the relationships
done right there's no way you're
convincing her that you care it's just
not happy yeah
the only way that you can the only way
that you can combat this politically is
by saying you know the people who you
say are caring we're actually not caring
because the truth is that in politics
nobody really cares that much about you
right okay the Democrats don't care
about you the Republicans don't care
about you no one cares about you I'm
honest enough to say listen here's what
I care about I care about my immediate
family I care about my circle of friends
and then the rest of you I want to leave
you alone right and that's good it's
good that I want to leave you alone I
don't care enough about you to try and
stop you I don't care enough about you
to try an input to try and somehow
infringe on your rights I don't care
enough about you to think I can control
your life my job is to get people out of
your way and to get everybody else out
of your way so you can do what you can
do and then it's your job to succeed
okay you're asking everybody else to
solve your problems I'm not gonna solve
your problems you're gonna solve your
own problems Democrats are lying to you
and they say they're gonna solve your
problems they're not Republicans are
lying to you and they say they're gonna
so I probably wonder why do that why do
they like that why is it that most
people like that I mean most people like
the idea that somebody's gonna come in
and solve their problems for them and if
you haven't grown up in in in a
community that suggests that it's your
job to solve your own problems and
suggests that you know where there have
been two generations of heavy levels of
dependence on government programs then
it's easy to equate that with caring I
don't blame people for that I mean it's
like you say it again you say that to
anybody you say I'm gonna take away you
know your Pell grants it's a bunch of
colleges and they and they say oh that's
terrible how could you tell by how Brown
you don't care about me
answer is you're right I don't care
about you neither do the people who are
give me the Pell grams people give you
the Pell grants don't care about you
either they just want your vote I care
about you enough to say listen you're on
your own go major in something that's
gonna make you some money right don't
take $120,000 and loan and go major and
lesbian dance theory or something they
could make it I'm gonna make a lot of
money right exactly like why don't you
go out and get a loan from a private
bank because they know they're gonna
have their money back
and they would actually be better for
you but that's your decision it's not my
job to sponsor your life
rule number seven cultivate your skill
set my wife is is a med student she's
about to graduate from UCLA med school
she's gonna be a doctor and and you know
my wife for example she actually did
something useful in college I studied
political science and wrote columns for
the paper you know and all that and the
only reason to do they I was so I could
get into Harvard Law School where I
where the first year is useful it gets
you to think like a lawyer then the last
two years are a way for them to rack up
loan so you have to work a big
so the truth is that my perspective on
college is basically I always thought
college was supposed to be for
developing a skill set no skill set is
reverting to being a two-year-old
mewling whining child so you're not
qualified to do anything after going
after after doing the kind of stuff
they're doing outside you're not
qualified to do anything or qualified
for a mental institution so the so you
know so as far as the you know as far as
getting a job afterward the question is
how do you cultivate your skill set what
cultivate your skill set so for me
cultivating my skill set meant reading
incessantly writing incessantly I mean I
wrote a book during college I wrote two
books during law school you know they it
meant it meant studying a lot it meant
using my degree for things that I wanted
to use my degree making moves in my
career that didn't make necessarily
monetary sense at the time and when I
first got out of law school I took a job
at a major law firm making a lot of
money and I decided I hated it and after
eight months I quit and I went to a job
that paid 1/3 as much and that's because
it wasn't a field that I liked rule
number eight clean up your mess and work
hard when I was young there are a couple
of rules in the house one of them was
that if you made him a she cleaned it up
and the other was that if you were not
working hard and weren't doing your job
and that those two things are gonna make
you a conservative I mean if you believe
that that responsibility lies with you
and that effort is the key then I think
that you're going to end up probably in
in a more conservative for a much just
because it's a very meritocratic basis
for living all successful people of any
stripe have to abide by those values I
don't think that those are political
values again I think that if you are
successful in life you have to abide by
those two simple rules you got to clean
up your own mess and you got to work
hard and so if you are successful then
it's a pretty good shot that somebody
along the way taught you those guys
because there are very few people who
leave messes for others or are lazy who
do really well in a free country rule
number nine stop making excuses
I believe that environment can create
culture can you acknowledge the
historical reasonings that led that
these so-called unsuccessful cultures
and not put blame on these minority
groups bad cultures do arise very often
from historical circumstances including
historical discrimination what I say is
that today there's nothing preventing an
individual from superseding the culture
in which you grew up and making the
decisions in the free country somebody's
have to break this chain somebody's
gonna have to break this cycle and so am
I gonna I don't care if you want to if
you want to say that that the pathology
that exists in the black community black
intercity community of highest rates of
single mothers and violence for example
or lack of institutional wealth that
that is a result of historic racism I'm
fine with you saying that I don't have
any problem with that I'm not talking
about historical races when I talk about
white privilege I'm talking about right
now the idea that there's a
superstructure of rules and laws that
are preventing you from succeeding or a
culture that is trying to keep you down
I don't think that's the case so the
question becomes if you are here let's
say let's say that on average the
culture in white America or with regard
single motherhood to take an example is
is here right because there's less
single mother in the white community
than black community and in the black
community it's it's here because it's
70% single motherhood rate in the white
community it's 40% okay so the question
is before thanks to racism and thanks to
discrimination there was a cap on the
black community that was here and they
couldn't get past it okay now the
ceilings been removed so what do you as
an individual black person do to change
your life and I don't think it's helpful
in fact I think it's actually quite
hurtful to spend an enormous amount of
time talking about the legacy of
discrimination and racism instead of
talking about what can you do right now
to fix your problem now this is a
general issue that I have in all of my
relationships when my wife comes to me
and she says there's a problem in my
life before we even have the
conversation I say to her is this a
listening conversation or is this a you
want me to fix a conversation
and I think that when it comes to
politics there should be far fewer
listening conversations like I want you
to tell me about all the crap that's
happening because I don't care I mean I
care but it doesn't but now the question
is what you're gonna do right that's a
much more important conversation because
we only have five minutes together is
that five minutes gonna be spent on all
the terrible things that happen which I
fully agree with that I would have
fought if I were there but I wasn't
right are we going to spend five minutes
talking about all the terrible things
that happen to Blacks and Jews and gays
and women and Hispanics in the United
States are we gonna talk about right now
what you can do to succeed because I
don't think that the rules are holding
you back so I've never ever at any point
suggested that there's not been historic
discrimination against black people or
even that current day poverty is at
least in part an outgrowth of that
historic discrimination where I have
suggested is that if you are using that
historic discrimination is a reason why
you are not as an individual human being
becoming more income mobile and not
making the decisions no one is making
the call for you right now as an
individual to get that girl pregnant and
that's that's the argument that I'm
making and rule number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
fight for what you stand for so I have a
few other thank yous I want to say thank
you to the morons who put up that sign
across the way and says we say no it's
your white supremacists [ __ ] well I
say thank you because I also say no to
white supremacist [ __ ] and if you
stick around long enough in this speech
you will hear me do exactly that the
problem is I also say no to your
identity politics [ __ ]
[Applause]
thanks to an Tifa and the supposed
anti-fascist brigade for exposing what
the radical left truly is all of America
is watching because you guys are so
stupid it's horrifying I am grateful and
you can all go to hell you pathetic
lying stupid jackasses I saw a lot of
headlines on the way here about how it's
gonna cost six hundred thousand dollars
in security for this event
and that is not to to me I mean I'm not
the one out threatening to break windows
it's not due to you you're here
listening it's due to the auntie feh
hard left morons who are out there
breaking windows and I do want to say
one thing which is that in a city as
left is Berkeley if you're gonna blame
me for the six hundred thousand dollars
in spending on security you're all canes
Ian's think of all the jobs I just
created there's a pathetic new movement
arising all over the country from
Sacramento to Berkeley to Dallas to
Charlottesville and that movement says
that speech is violence and must be
treated as such
this is groups like refuse fashions the
world gets the all right later this is
groups like refused fascism which
professes to promote protest but has
actually said it won't rule out working
with groups like an Tifa here is the
poster that they put out earlier about
me I don't know who designs their
posters but guys this is too many words
just bad logo and bad imagery just
poorly done they say on this that the
problem is not campus thuggery for those
you can't say this is no ben shapiro the
problem is not campus thuggery the
problem is fascist intellectual thuggery
in the service of the trump pense
fascist regime well to believe this you
have to have your head so far up your
ass you can actually see your colon
firsthand
[Music]
now I've got a bonus ben shapiro clip on
how to find your gift that i think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your comments and if you're
feeling bold leave your replies in the
comments below here we go question
number one what excuses are you making
that you need to stop number two how can
you be more resourceful to achieve your
goal and number three what skills do you
need to cultivate to make your dreams
your brain moves a million miles a
second you're just gonna it's gonna so
like and when I watch your eyes if so
many thoughts come out so quickly but
it's so perfect like perfect melody when
it comes out have you always been like
this since you were a kid yeah I always
was able to articulate my thoughts
relatively clearly and I think it's
gotten better as I've gotten older I
mean I hope I don't speak the same way I
did when I was two but so I mean I was
winning speech contests when I was in
third grade so it's not it's not a
winning speech concentrators when I was
in third yeah so were you the kid that
you always debate Oh your mom and dad
mom I don't know if I agree with this
dad I know my were you dad nothing then
I got along with my parents really well
okay I still get along for my parents
really well they'll burn mile away so
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon
[Music]
if you liked this video I highly
recommend checking out the top 10 we did
on Jordan Peterson the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there it's important to distinguish
between those because that's partly and
this is back down to the micro routine
analysis so as I was saying while you're
gonna try to make yourself more
industrious